a great day
let me jump right now then right
into introducing our first keynote
speaker
and that is stoic dan so he
is going to be talking about stoicism
and the american transcendentalist
i'm particularly looking forward to this
talk as
somebody who studies them myself stoic
dan
is somebody who is there's that old
word in defect indefatigable i think is
how it's pronounced
um the person who is you know constantly
exuding
energy and so stoic dan is one of those
people uh he has five meetups
that he has started and
is running for the purpose of you know
introducing people to philosophy that's
a lot of work
just just one meetup is already a lot of
work so i don't i don't know
quite how he does it and these these
focus on stoicism minimalism
american transcendentalism i'm really
looking forward to
his talk so dan if you wouldn't mind
going off uh
mute okay great thanks for that super
introduction greg
i am stoic dan from orlando and uh today
i'm talking about the
linkages that we can find between the
american transcendentalists and
the modern stoicism movement today
the american transcendentalist for those
of you who know your history
that's uh ralph waldo emerson
and henry david thoreau and also
margaret fuller
there was actually a broader group of
people involved in that movement in the
mid
1800s and we're just going to talk about
three of them briefly today emerson
thoreau
and fuller and their ideas as well as
their contributions
and um one of the uh the things
let's see if dan hayes could allow me to
share my screen
i'm going to start with emerson and uh
he was um obviously a philosopher
a poet a lecturer not all of you may
know
that he was a unitarian minister also
emerson played
a role in the unitarian history
and he was a leading figure in the
transcendentalist movement that's not
just my opinion that's also
uh what most scholars agree
and um let's see
here
so um his topics his main topics that he
wrote about in his essays and in his
lectures of the time
was that he wrote about individuality
virtue
freedom and non-conformity uh
the first essay of his that caught my
attention
was called self-reliance uh this is a
word that comes up
uh in many um uh stoic conversations
today
but in his essay which started as a
sermon in 1830
one of his famous quotes from the
self-reliance
essay is he says quote trust thyself
every heart by vibrates to that iron
string
except the place the divine providence
has found for you
the society of your contemporaries and
the connection
of events
now in this essay uh some of his general
themes
are individualism that is the moral
worth of a person
and he also cautions readers to follow
their own will rather than conforming to
society
and to the church at that time the
influences
on this essay self-reliance was that he
took a trip to europe and had
conversations with other great thinkers
of the time
like coleridge and carlisle and in terms
of stoicism
i think the the theme from this essay
that comes through is that
he says the divine is in you it's like
it's like what we talk of in stoicism
that the spark of the universe
is in each of us and i think that
um translating that to today
conformity is a very important issue for
today
we have the young people young adults
and kids who are inundated with
social media and news and even violent
video games and things like that
are they going to conform to those
things or are they going to be more
skeptical thinkers
the next essay that i'd like to briefly
cover for emerson
is his essay called history this came
from a lecture in 1837
and he says there quote there is one
mind common to all
individual men every man is an inlet to
the same
and to all of the same he that is once
admitted to the right of reason
is made a freeman of the whole estate
who hath access to the universal mind is
a party
to all that is or can be done for this
is the only and sovereign
agent well some of the key words that
he's using there
like reason and a free person or a free
man
is very close to the stoic writings that
talk about um
us using reason so that we have freedom
from things like worry stress and
anxiety
and um sometimes i will criticize the
internet
uh but i'll praise it for a moment i'll
say that if emerson were alive today he
might be amazed
at the power of the internet to connect
minds and share knowledge
uh his next essay very quickly is uh
called the oversoul this was first
published in 1841
and there he says quote the soul's
advances
are not made by gradation such as can be
represented by motion
in a straight line but rather the
ascension of state such as can be
represented by metamorphosis
from the egg to the worm from the worm
to the fly
and in general i think what he's
describing here is not only his belief
in god
but um i think he's also saying that
with
um that academics could consider this
essay
more of a um a little bit on the
mystical side
but he is describing about the role of
god in our lives
and that we can communicate with him
without the help of the church that was
the important thing
is emerson is trying to make us
independent thinkers
all right the next essay is called woman
and here he's talking about the
importance of women
in society uh this is something uh
similar to how the ancient stoics were
described they
they often uh well we often talk about
them as being forward thinking in terms
of women
and their role in society here emerson
says quote
the part they play in education in the
care of the young and the tuition
of older children is their organic
office in the world
so much sympathy as they have makes them
inestimable as the mediators between
those
who have knowledge and those who want it
so he's saying in this essay he's
promoting the
moral worth of women and this would
surface later by the way
in unitarian values such as justice
human relations and the world community
so i think emerson was ahead of his time
in terms of his esteem for women i've
got two more brief
essays to cover uh one is called the
american scholar
which came from a lecture in 1837
and here he says quote the first in time
and the first in importance of the
influences upon the mind
is that of nature every day the sun
and after sunset night and her stars
ever the winds blow ever the grass grows
there is never a beginning
there is never an end to the
inexplicable continuity of this web of
god
but always circular power returning into
itself
well uh the scholars uh
talk about this essay called the
american scholar
and um they observed that
emerson is talking about actions and
work
about our in other words our actions and
our work in our lives
and it sounds a lot like aristotle's
writings in the nicomachean ethics
which defines ethics and excellence
not by what by what we say but what we
repeatedly do now the final essay for
emerson
is uh what some people remember him most
for it's called the divinity school
address
uh this lecture and sermon was given on
an
evening in july of 1838
and he was speaking to the graduating
class of harvard's divinity school
we are told by the records that there
were only about a hundred people there
that evening and only six of them were
graduates of the school the rest of them
were faculty
and parents and friends but boy did they
react
to what he had to say uh the quote that
i've chosen for this one is
quote while the doors of the temple
stand open night and day before every
man and the oracles of this truth
cease never it is guarded by one stern
condition
this namely it is an intuition
it cannot be received at second hand
truly
speaking it is not instruction but
provocation
that i can receive from another soul
what he announces
i must find true in me or holy reject
and on his word
or as his second be he who he may i can
accept
nothing he's basically saying that he
doesn't want to receive
information second hand whether we're
talking about
the words of the bible or the other
instructions from the institution of the
church
he's basically saying that we should be
independent thinkers
and we should be experiencing life
firsthand
he also as a result he advises
the the graduates in that class
uh graduating class that evening he
wants them to be
um telling their own stories in other
words finding their own message in life
and he doesn't want to just resort to
the scriptures that are frozen in time
so he wants to make them more
independent thinkers
all right i'm going to take a sip here
to drink and next we're moving on to
henry david thoreau
well first of all for those of you who
are interested
in the pronunciation side
of his name remember that most of us
including scholars
call him thoreau henry david thoreau but
his family
actually produced or pronounced uh his
name as
thorough and uh that's an interesting
bit of trivia
there but overall he's self-described as
a mystic a transcendentalist and a
natural philosopher
and his writings covered society
the individual and the search for
universal laws
so i'm going to review quickly three
essays here and then
say something about his book walden
the um the first essay for which he's
probably most
uh famous for is called civil
disobedience
uh this was published in 1849
and the quote here is the mass of men
served the state thus not as men mainly
but as machines
with their bodies and thoreau
is having a feeling here that people
don't question government enough and
should instead act on their own
principles
even when this is against the law uh
it's also
a reference to rousseau and his social
contract
which came about a hundred years before
the questions there were
what government should we set up and
monarchs are not divinely empowered
but the important part here is for
transcendence and the transcendentalist
movement
is thoreau wants us to have less
government and more freedom
he also says that society although it
has
its values it is nonetheless a
distraction
and so we should not always go with the
herd and we should be using our own
moral compass the next famous essay is
called slavery in massachusetts
this was a lecture from 1854
and the quote that i'll start with here
is
three years ago also just a week after
the authorities of boston
assembled to carry back a perfectly
innocent man
and one whom they knew to be innocent
into slavery
the inhabitants of concord caused the
bells to be wrong
and the cannons to be fired to celebrate
their own liberty
well what he's talking about here is
he's talking about the massachusetts
law at that time that although they did
not have slaves
in the state they did by law
return slaves who were fleeing the south
they would return them to their slave
owners in the south
and this made thoreau quite upset um
he pointed out the in the celebration
mentioned in that quote
he points out the hypocrisy of
celebrating one's own freedoms and yet
sending people back
into slavery so the transcendent part of
this
essay is that we must recognize what is
morally right
despite what laws there may be on the
books
okay next essay is walking
a essay called walking uh this comes
from a lecture he gave in 1851
and here he says quote i wish to speak a
word
for nature for absolute freedom and
wildness
as contrasted with a freedom and culture
merely civil
to regard man as an inhabitant or a part
and parcel of nature
rather than a member of society i wish
to make an extreme statement if so
i may make an emphatic one for there is
enough
champions of civilization the minister
and the school committee
and every one of you will take care of
that well here he's explaining that part
of nature
the part of the wildness that we need to
explore
and he believed very firmly that when we
do explore nature that we rediscover our
true selves
the transcendent part of this is um the
modern author richard schneider
his bio says that thoreau is looking for
absolute freedom not civil liberty
and thoreau's wildness is opposite of
city
and culture so this is finding our other
selves in other words
now of course for those of you who've
studied
stoicism for a while you'll realize that
the ancient stoic writings often talk of
living according to nature
and although i don't think that's
exactly what thoreau is discussing here
but i do think that
thoreau and emerson may have been
inspired by those words that were often
repeated
living according to nature i think that
could have been an influence on them
finally we come to the rose book called
walden
from 1854. this was
in many ways his own personal story or
declaration
of his uh well the subtitle of the book
used to be called life in the woods
and most of us who've read about this we
know that he
did live in the woods for two years and
two months
but it's also important to recognize the
history that
he did often go back to emerson's house
which was just a couple miles away
so that's uh not often uh or not
described too much in the history but it
is a fact
the important part of walden is that he
moved there in 1845
and he was working on another book at
the time
but he found in doing in living at
walden he found that he could sustain
himself by cultivating the land
and working uh occasionally as a
surveyor and a carpenter and that's how
he earned his living
chapter two of the book walden starts
with the famous line
i went to the woods because i wished to
live deliberately
and i often pick out this line because
thoreau is using words like deliberately
and later in the quote essential
he's talking about things that today are
very important to the minimalist
movement
which has a lot of connections to
stoicism as well
to live simply or in stoicism as we say
if we can live with less
then we'll be rich indeed well
the book walden is also popular because
it's part storytelling and complex
metaphors
and if you haven't read it yet it's uh
certainly
relevant for modern times the stanford
encyclopedia
describes the book as saying it almost
defies
categorization it is a work of narrative
prose
which often soars to poetic heights
combining philosophical speculation with
close observation
of a concrete place it is a rousing
summons to an examined life
and the realization of one's potential
well i hope you will take a look at
walden of any of the essays or or books
that i've mentioned
i think it really is a uh an important
book for modern times
because in that book thoreau is showing
us how he can practice a simple living
he can also be okay with solid solitude
and of course self-reliance he's very
self-reliant in this book
he grew his own food and so in so doing
i think that he's
understanding reality a little bit
better and finding wisdom he wasn't just
talking about
the philosophy for uh just an abstract
sense he really wanted to make it
a lived philosophy as we talk about for
stoicism
okay well i'm nearly i want to wrap up
now so we have time for
q a the next person that i want to talk
about
is margaret fuller i've included her
here
because although she's not discussed
enough
in the modern i'm sorry in the american
transcendentalism movement
i do include her because one of my areas
of study is
women in philosophy and
margaret fuller was the author of five
books and 350 essays at the time
that she lived in her career she was
actually a journalist and a critic but
she was noted as a great philosopher of
her times
the themes are that we
in society are burdened by selfish
desires that sounds like a very stoked
thing to say
and we're also on the verge of a
spiritual awakening
she became the editor of the dial
magazine which was the official magazine
of the american transcendentalist
movement
and she became editor of it
in 1840
this is actually what you see here on
the screen
i believe is one of the first edition
copies
that were published so
that's the fascinating thing about um
[Music]
about the internet as we can retrieve
those things
but uh also let me go to the next slide
here
she also published a famous book called
woman in the 19th century
and um notice that that the title is not
women
of the 19th century but woman in the
19th century
and she's taking a closer look at the
role of women in society and even in
philosophy
all right well that brings me to the end
of uh this presentation
um overall i think you'll find if you uh
do some googling you'll find that the
american transcendentalist movement
started about 1830
went to 1860 it's a relatively short
period like 30 years
i believe that these people from the
transcendentalist movement held high
very very much the value of reason and
intellect there are lots of direct
matches to stoic writings there
and they were also very much for stoic
um i'm sorry for personal freedoms
they wanted to learn things firsthand
they didn't want to just take the word
of others
i know this is something that this
sentiment is very important today
because
when we talk about bringing philosophy
into the modern age
i think that skepticism of the american
transcendentalist movement is very
helpful today
not just in terms of our views of
society but also of the internet
there's a lot of things we can read on
the internet that we should be aware of
um so um let's see how can i wrap this
up
um i think that uh
overall that's that theme of
self-reliance is something that we can
learn from this american transcendence
movement and bring into the present
and um now we're going to have time for
q a i thank you for your attention so
far
gregory how would you like to handle the
q a i'll um
i'll i'll read the questions out loud to
you as people
bring them in um so
i've actually got one for you that that
piggybacks off of what you were just
saying about
the need to be self-reliant and
sort of uh experiment you know figure
out for oneself
it strikes me that one of the things
that makes modern
stoicism modern stoicism is exactly that
that um you you know instead of just
like say well seneca said this so it
must be true
you know you you try to apply it and
then you see
what things work and what things don't
work and maybe that might lead to saying
some
some things aren't very helpful and we
can put them to the side but some things
are incredibly helpful
and we want to keep doing more of those
so is that i mean do you see that as a
interconnection between stoicism as a
way of of living a philosophical life
and transcendentalism
yes i do actually what your comment or
question reminds me of
is that uh think of how many times today
in modern stories and we talk about
dealing with discomfort you know putting
ourselves through a little test
like oh i can do without air
conditioning or i can do without
my car this weekend well consider what
thoreau did he went and lived in the
woods mostly for two years and two
months
and was self-sufficient he would grow
most of his own food
and he would in his journal in walden
what's really fascinating to me
is he sometimes writes his budget out in
pennies
you know so many pennies to buy beans
for this and
to plant them in the field and he talks
about uh
farming them he really put himself
through
a form of discomfort but of course to
him it was actually preferable he wanted
to be in nature so
he saw it from both sides there
so this is a good question coming from
timothy
uh right about exactly that what truth
or truths did thoreau gain from his
living in nature
right this is and this is an area that
not only did he find a way to grow his
own food and live on very simple means
but much like stoicism you know
sometimes we talk about nero
i'm sorry um talk about seneca and
marcus aurelius
as being so wealthy and yet they talk
about simple living
well that same criticism or controversy
controversy might be applied to thoreau
because we do know
from the history that he did go back to
emerson's house sometimes
when he needed clothes washed or to have
dinner with the emersons
so there is a little bit of controversy
there but essentially i believe he did
live
in the woods for long periods and was
self-sufficient
so here's two things uh both from the
new england stoix happy to have them
represented here uh peter fagella this
is not a question but here in new
england you can visit walden pond and
the houses of thoreau
and emerson and then marc deschez says
if you were to recommend one place to
start which of the sources
would a person start with to learn more
about these three thinkers emerson
self-reliance
walden walking so that's that's a good
question there
yeah i would start with self-reliance
it's uh it's a short essay
and uh very meaningful i mean it's um
like
it seems like every paragraph in there
is quotable but uh
self-reliance is a great place to start
so here's a question from nick i've been
intrigued by thoreau for some time i've
never thought of him as having a stoic
view does he ever mention stoic teaching
specifically do you think his writing
also indicates influence from other
schools of thought if
so which ones yeah that's a very
important question
uh it's not just the uh uh
the um it's not just a conclusion that
scholars have formed that
they followed stoics or they read about
the stoics
it's actually mentioned in their
journals that they
that they were well read and that did
include the ancient writings of the
stoic so we know for certain
that the stoics were an influence on the
american transcendentalists
oh here's here's another uh really
useful one from sean
my impression of transcendentalism is a
lot of emphasis
on contemplation what i mean by that is
not exactly thought
but an awareness beyond thought does
that make sense and stoicism thought
is also is so all-important is there a
component of stoicism that involves that
kind of
contemplation contemplation yes
well it's um one of the themes that runs
through
these writers emerson thoreau and fuller
is
they are focusing on the individual to
develop themselves
um i mean this is of course where the
uh the name transcendentalism comes from
is you are transcending you are growing
as an individual or you are having
spiritual growth as another phrase
might say it and so that development of
the individual
is is not only important for the
individual to have a better
view or perspective of the world but
also
there's another essay american scholar
where the message is that you should not
only develop yourself but you
might contribute back to the community
you might be the next great thinker or
writer
as they say an american scholar where
you can really bring a positive impact
on society
and therein is a link to the cosmopolis
the uh
modern stoic term that we're using a lot
now
so that is a perfect segue into the next
question uh this is from mark i
discovered through through anarchism
though i wouldn't consider him one
however he does seem to present
on something that cosmopolitan
perspective is that a correct assessment
could you please say a bit on that
yeah i would say that thoreau would be
uh would have mixed views about that
um when i started reading thoreau
i had a view that he was just
anti-society that he wanted to stay away
from it he wanted to
live in the woods but as you read more
you'll see that he does
value some things that society offers
you know
for example in town there's uh people
are growing food and bringing that to
market
a lot of things are happening there that
if you had to do it all by yourself
it would be a lot of work clothing all
different textiles
things they had even back then in the in
the mid-1800s
he did value those things but he also
cautioned
people that if you go with the herd
completely and you
are just believing everything society
tells you
then you're missing a lot and he wanted
us to be more of a free thinker
in terms of cosmopolitanism i think that
thoreau did have a great interest in
learning from people for example in
walden
he had he talks about several evenings
several conversations he had with
neighbors with people
who were passing through and he really
enjoyed that enough that conversation
he enjoyed it enough to share it in the
book
but i think that um he might also be a
little bit fearful going to town he
might shy away from that so
he was a mixture of ideas
here is a question from timothy
how does buddhism or mindfulness tie
into these writers
ah that's a good question
i don't compare them much to buddhism
but in terms of
the mindfulness i think that when you
just start
in the first couple of chapters of
walden
i could argue that he's being very
mindful you'll see him
listing in his book his grocery list
you know that he went to the the store
and he bought some beans
and he will talk about how he spent two
dollars and three cents on it
he's very much in the moment he's very
much focused
on his grocery list because he knows
that those beans are going to be brought
home to the cabin
he's going to plant them in the field
and when they
grow and he's going to harvest them
that's going to be his food
for the winter perhaps so i think he is
very mindful
in in that respect for sure
so while we're waiting for some other
questions to
come through the text i'll i'll ask um
you know you you've mentioned this um
sort of needing to to free oneself of of
conventions
um would that would that make thoreau
and emerson and fuller more like
cynics than the the stoics or
do you see them as as still pretty
compatible
well that's that's a good observation
the cynics were very
cynical about society and uh thoreau and
emerson
uh certainly had that uh aspect to their
writings
i think that um uh i think that
more research would be uh would be
interesting in this topic because
if we look back to why the cynics were
um anti-society you know they
i remember they they walked in the
streets they were homeless they
didn't go by social conventions
thoreau and emerson were somewhat social
but i think that they also valued the
wildness
or the wilderness uh very much like some
of their contemporaries at the time you
know whitman also wrote about uh the
value of nature
and um i think so i think that so to
answer your question i think they were
their own flavor of cynics
they uh they had big questions about
society
all right so there's um two questions
here actually about
throws civil disobedience
let's take the the more broad one first
then we'll come back to doug's
in in a minute for this from mark do you
see any stoic influences
in thoreau's civil disobedience
stoic influence in civil disobedience
well um
in my mind i'm connecting the idea of
what basically what
thoreau was telling us is that if
um if the laws that society give us
are immoral that we should we should
protest them
and we should work against them and of
course thoreau is also famous for ending
up in jail for not paying his
taxes uh but um that was his way of
protesting in a way
[Music]
i also think that i'm also going back in
my mind that i think there's a quote by
marcus aurelius
that says that if i have to choose
between
the roman law and the higher laws
that i will choose the latter i've i'm
i'm probably paraphrasing
marcus aurelius there but it's the same
concept is that if there is a law that's
immoral
that we need to um we need to protest
so that's actually a good lead-in to
doug's
about throws civil disobedience how
would you compare
that to stoic views on the duty of the
individual
in society i think some people just to
piggyback off of that
might view stoicism as saying well you
should be a conformist
don't rock the boat you know uh stick to
your little
place and and don't cause any any issues
but that's not really the stoic view
right
correct uh in fact i i remember uh one
of my favorite quotes about this is by
massimo
where he talks about that you know in a
recent talk in the pandemic massimo was
saying that uh
stoics are not passive we have to
remember that we are active
in every aspect of our lives and though
we may seem to be uh sitting there
passively
but actually what we're doing is we're
thinking about what am i going to say
next what am i going to do next
so we are employing reason in that
regard
and of course when thoreau wrote civil
disobedience there were a lot of things
going on
at the time in american culture
he was very much against slavery
and uh he didn't just talk about it or
lecture about it
he did participate in the underground
slave
i forget what that was called the the
movement to get slaves out of the south
the railroad yeah or the railroad right
you know so i'm going to read dan's in
just a moment but that reminds me of
something when i i needed to get
civil disobedience because i was
teaching it in class so i got
a library copy and in there there's a
really interesting
essay where he is praising john brown
after john brown's raid on harper's
ferry
and a lot of people in the north were
even condemning john brown
basically saying well we agree with his
sentiments you know we're against
slavery
but you know you can't engage in armed
insurrection
and thoreau praises him um
so i'm going to ask you this do you
think he's being is he
self-contradictory and praising
john brown for what he's engaging in or
is this a matter of
uh following principle yeah this is a
a difficult subject for american
transcendentalists but i must admit
that thoreau was praising someone that i
think
thoreau had mixed feelings about
i think later in his journals he has
some comments that he he didn't like
what john brown was doing of course
because there was
a lot of violence and death there um
i think that basically what happened was
is both thoreau and emerson
were praising john brown in one aspect
for not accepting the way things are
but they also had reservations about the
violence that he used
so uh they had mixed feelings but the
of course the essays and the writings
that have come down through history
uh we can cherry pick just one side and
say well he
he supported him but i think there was a
mixed feeling there
also for those of you who are um i
forget i think it's on
hbo or showtime there's actually a
series on john brown
that is playing weekly on sundays right
now
and i think ethan hawke is the um is the
actor who plays the lead role
so uh that's uh one way you can get
involved with
modern philosophy is looking back on
that history
well that's that's nice because it's so
rare that you get philosophy
in popular culture in that way
so here's a question from dan hayes what
have you gained personally from your
study of the transcendentalists and how
have you
implemented that in your day-to-day life
are there any practices that come
directly
from them yeah it's uh i enjoy nature
very much also
and so i i do in this pandemic i've been
walking a lot in parks
um and uh and sometimes i just sit
in a park you know where they have a
convenient bench and i'll just look at
the sky
and the trees a real appreciation for
nature and it's
um it's something that i've i've always
done through my life but now i make it a
regular practice
and i find that in this pandemic when
often we're
stuck at home a lot or more than we
would like
uh going out to a park even a park that
is
empty sometimes there are parks you may
find in your area that
have very few people at but still you
can enjoy the park for its nature
that's interesting is is it possible to
combine that with our as the stoics
teach us our social
communal nature um you know
by socially distancing walks
in parks or things like that yes
the orlando stoics started years ago
with
uh one walk per month it was on i think
the
second or third sunday but over time it
got more popular
and then we had it on every sunday um
which and best of all the members
actually suggested different parks in
orlando that were
extremely beautiful um you know like
we have a park near princeton street
it's called um
lock haven park and it's got such old
trees and interesting landscaping and an
irregular shaped
lake that we can walk around there's
also part of
part of the trip is a boardwalk part of
it is sidewalks
it's such a beautiful area and of course
we're in the rainy season now
where it rains every afternoon so we had
to put a little
hiatus on the on the walks but
uh the orlando stoics did practice
walking meditations every sunday
and we're going to get back to it also
this might actually be a good
time for dan hayes to just say a little
bit about
experimenting with exactly that that
same thing up here in milwaukee
obviously
you can't do it year round like you can
in orlando
but uh so
i came to it from my time when i was
living
in the san francisco bay area and i was
hanging out with
the fremont stoics and we went to lake
elizabeth
and we walked around there uh weekly and
so
i tried to take that and bring it back
with me when i move back here to
milwaukee
in order to try to you know recreate
this
experience of interacting with nature
and then interacting with
um some of the stoic teachings as well
as building community
great and also i'll add one thing i
found
that i didn't expect to find but in the
walking meditations that we have in
orlando
uh the people who come there tend to be
not the ones who come to the
formal discussions and it's because they
just want to talk about
they don't want to have an agenda or
anything planned out like i usually do
in my outlines but they want to just
have a free
discussion maybe about stoicism or
philosophy in general
maybe other topics maybe they just want
to ask me hey i'm getting
interested in stoicism what can you tell
me about it to get me started
so it's very important i think for our
group that
the walking meditations are a
non-structured format that gives people
the freedom to cover a lot of what they
want to talk about
that's actually a good point that i
think maybe we'll take up a little bit
more
in the panel towards the end of the day
i'm talking about like what sort of
formats and
whether it's better to have one or
several different kinds of
events throughout the month for for
stoic
meetups
great any other last questions
for for dan while we've got him here to
tap his
mind about stoicism and the
transcendentalists
we'll give it just a minute and uh if we
don't have any then then we'll
we'll sign off a little bit early we're
going to have a brief break
and then we'll be bringing up our second
speaker
meredith cons who's be talking about
a quick start guide to stoic parenting
i'll do an introduction of her
at that time it doesn't look likely like
we have any other questions so
if i had a applause and clapping
uh sound thing handy i'd be playing that
right now
but people can weigh in and chat if they
want to
thanks very much for for coming and
giving this
this talk yeah thanks for the
opportunity
you